-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We're very happy
you're here with us tonight.
And now we are going to
get to the news.
Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer said yesterday
that President Biden's
"Build Back Better" agenda
will come up for a vote
before Christmas,
which is good,
because right now,
that manger is,
like, our sturdiest building.
President Biden
visited General Motors'
so-called Factory ZERO
electric-vehicle assembly plant
today in Michigan.
And you could
tell he was impressed.
He kept saying,
"So it's fully electric?
No horses at all?"
Jacob Chansley, also known as
the QAnon Shaman
from the January Capitol
insurrection has been sentenced
to 41 months in prison.
Apparently, it's hard to find
a jury of his peers
the same day there's a
Renaissance fair.
It's been announced that
the Los Angeles Staples Center
will change its name to
the Crypto.com Arena.
So look for the Lakers to be up
by 20, then back down by 40,
then up by 10,000,
then back to zero.
Montana Senator Jon Tester
joked with reporter yesterday
that he expects
Democratic efforts to pass
President Biden's
"Build Back Better" agenda
to screw up his holiday plans.
Well, if it makes you
feel any better,
you're a Democrat in Montana.
Your relatives probably don't
want to see you anyway.
The New Year's Eve celebration
in Times Square
will return in person this year
for participants
who are fully vaccinated
against the coronavirus.
But if you're unvaccinated,
you'll have to settle
for going to the Super Bowl.
Officials in
Florida recently discovered
a 20-foot-long metal box
washed up on a beach.
Even weirder,
there wasn't any cocaine in it.
Well, now I've
seen everything, Florida.
Google Cloud services
experienced an outage yesterday
which caused the music
platform Spotify to crash,
costing artists a total
of over 75 cents in profits.
Costco and Kraft Heinz
issued a recall last week
for Kool-Aid drink mix due to
possible contamination of
small pieces of metal or glass.
Okay, well, here's a suggestion.
Stop delivering it
through walls.
That's modern, right?
That's still -- That's, like,
a modern ad campaign?
[ Laughter ]
I'm really excited
about this one.
The sex-toy company
Dame Products
announced this week that it
has settled its lawsuit
with New York's MTA
and will be allowed to advertise
the brand on the subway,
though still no plan in place to
make the train come faster.
[ Cheers and applause ]
First down!
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, boxer --
Former professional boxer --
And, finally, former
professional boxer Mike Tyson
said in a new interview
that he takes
Sonoran Desert tone venom --
We're going to reboot and we're
going to get this right.
I'm just so excited about that
"train come faster" joke.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
Like, I know everybody's like,
"Move on to the next joke,"
but I want to live
in the last one.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, former
professional boxer Mike Tyson
said in a new interview that he
takes Sonoran Desert toad venom
to hallucinate.
Responded the interviewer,
"I'm a lamp."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, you guys,
that was the monologue.